So we've been waiting for it.
And it's happening.
Donald Trump is now publicly saying he believes
that foreign countries.
He won't say which ones will be rigging the
upcoming presidential election against him.
This is particularly funny, to use a word
that really lightens the situation.
It's really tragic, but it's sort of funny
for Trump to predict that other countries
will rig the election against him, since he
has repeatedly said he would consider accepting
help from other countries and according to
John Bolton, even asked China for help.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
Let's let's wait for a moment, because there's
a few stories here.
First is that in general, Donald Trump has
appeared to be particularly on tilt over the
last few weeks.
On tilt is a term from chess and poker, sometimes
from other games, where when you take a bad
beat, you make a mistake or you appear to
get unlucky or you make an error, then it
influences your future behavior and you behave
even more radically during future games and
moments.
And that seems to be.
What what's going on with Donald Trump yet?
His failed rally on Saturday in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
slumping into the White House with a tan stained
white shirt out of his helicopter on late
Saturday night, reportedly yelling at his
staff for the lack of turnout.
We covered it all yesterday.
Meanwhile, he sees that polling is not looking
so good.
And now Donald Trump is loudly and wildly
proclaiming that foreign countries are going
to rig the election against him.
And this is another instance of Donald Trump.
Maybe we don't really know what he's doing.
And it may not even be a, you know, a thought
out strategy, but he may be laying the groundwork
to contest the results of the election in
the future.
When he loses, he could argue he didn't really
lose because it was rigged.
And he's been talking about it being rigged
and priming his followers to believe it will
be rigged for months.
Trump writing yesterday on Twitter, quote,
This is all caps, by the way.
I'm not going to do anything in my reading
to reflect that.
It's all caps.
Just know that it's all caps rigged.
Twenty twenty election, millions of mail in
ballots will be printed by foreign countries
and others.
It will be the scandal of our times.
Then tweeting minutes later, because of all
caps mail in ballots, 20-20 will be the most
rigged capital e election in our nation's
history.
No apostrophe on nations unless this stupidity
is ended.
We voted during World War One and World War
Two with no problem, but now they are using
coded in order to cheat by using Maylands.
That's the president, by the way.
That's not some conspiracy theorist who's
like a third stringer, Alex Jones tweeting
that that's the president of the United States,
at least for a few more months.
So remember, he spent the last three and a
half years arguing that an election he won
was rigged against him.
So, of course, he's going to say that it was
rigged.
If indeed he loses and this is a particularly
unhinged claim, foreign countries are going
to print ballots and what, fill them in and
send them to low local polling precincts?
Like, what's funny about this is that Trump
know so little about how voting works that
he seems to think this could be an actual
thing that could be done, like Trump has been
on this unhinged crusade against vote by mail
for a couple of months now, saying it leads
to fraud and so on and so forth.
Here he says the fraud would be foreign countries
would print massive numbers of ballots.
All, I guess, perfectly formatted to match
the format of any particular precinct.
Fill them in as votes for Biden and then send
them by mail.
Now, absentee ballots, as you may know, are
only sent to registered voters.
Like if you send in a thousand ballots saying,
oh, Joe Smith voted for Biden and Nancy Smith
voted for Biden and Joe Smith Junior voted
for Biden and Joe Smith, the third.
Like when they're received, they're checked
against a registered voter list in that precinct.
If that person isn't actually registered to
vote in that precinct, then the ballot is
thrown out.
If the person already submitted a ballot,
then another one coming in with their same
name is going to be thrown out and not counted.
This would be an insanely stupid way to try
to steal an election.
And then, by the way, so layer one is Trump
is until layer two is this is a dumb way to
steal an election.
Number three is it's particularly stunning
that Trump is decrying foreign interference,
because you might remember that in an interview
with George Stephanopoulos, he was actually
asked, you know, if Russia offered help, dirt,
so to speak, if China offered it, would you
accept it?
And Trump said that he might.
Let me remind you about that interview from
a few months back.
This is somebody that said we have information
on your opponent.
Oh.
Let me call the FBI.
Give me a break.
Life as a director says that's what should
happen.
The FBI director is wrong.
Your campaign this time around is foreigners.
If Russia, if China if someone else offers
you information upon it, should they accept
it or should they call the FBI?
I think maybe you do both.
I think you might want to listen.
I don't there's nothing wrong with listening.
If somebody called from a country in Norway,
we have information on your opponent.
Oh, I think I'd want to hear you want that
kind of interference in our elections.
It's not an interference.
I have information.
I think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong.
I'd go maybe to the FBI if I thought there
was something wrong.
But when somebody comes up with Apple Research,
right, they come up with a research, oh, let's
call the FBI.
The FBI doesn't have enough agents to take
care of it.
But you go and talk honestly to congressmen.
They all do it.
They always have.
And that's the way it is.
It's called oppo research.
Now, the reason Trump is doing this is very
clear.
He's seen the polls and he's scared.
You know, publicly he claims every poll is
fake.
If it says that he's losing, even when it's
a Fox News poll, even when it's a Rasmussen
poll.
But privately, we've heard reports that Trump
is absolutely furious with his staff.
He doesn't understand how he's losing so badly.
Fox News had Biden ahead by 12 last Thursday.
Quinnipiac had Biden ahead by eight.
CNBC has Biden plus 10.
Economist has Biden up nine.
New poll out of New Hampshire says Biden is
plus seven.
That was tied almost in 2016.
Poll says Biden plus seven.
There's a Florida poll that says Biden plus
seven.
I find that a little bit hard to believe.
But then a tip poll has Biden plus eleven
in Florida.
It's insane is the point.
And we all have to vote.
But clearly, Donald Trump is triggered by
the polling.
So now we'll wait and see what happens in
November.
But the important thing to address here is
that if Donald Trump thinks foreign countries
are going to rig the election against him,
why hasn't he done anything about it?
If it was rigged in 2016 against Trump and
he believes it will be rigged in 2020 against
him, why is it that for the last three and
a half years, despite numerous attempts from
mostly Democrats to actually toughen up and
harden our election systems so they are not
subject to foreign interference?
Why has Trump opposed all of those measures?
Why is Miss Mitch McConnell opposed?
All of those measures and ideas that have
been put forward, it's because any good story
needs an enemy.
And here the enemy is so-called foreign votes,
mail in boats, double voting, et cetera, et
cetera.
It's not real.
And the final sort of insanity and hypocrisy
here is once again that this is something
that Trump allegedly went out and solicited,
according to John Bolton.
It's not just what Trump said to George Stephanopoulos.
Well, if they sent it to me, I'd look at it.
It's actually the allegation is that Trump
went to the Chinese president and said, listen,
I need farmers to help get me reelected in
November of 2020.
Can you start buying more stuff from our farmers
to help me get reelected?
It's not just he would be willing to accept
it.
It's he allegedly went out and solicited it.
And that's what makes this all so, so insane.
Now, let's talk about the next level of crazy,
which is Donald Trump coming out against the
First Amendment here in the United States.